so I start off with the deep apology for
the delay and setting up so good so here
I am finally and I would like to talk to
you today about some work that I'm doing
in building machine learning algorithms
for particular domain and this has to do
with debt collection so in case I've run
out of time I don't get to the end of
the presentation here's the message that
basically humans determine determining
the amount of money that we offer as
discounts to people who owe debt humans
are biased machine learning algorithms
learn the bias very nicely in fact but
machines can be trained to be unbiased
and so you should all be doing bias
analysis in your work okay so now we
dive in a little bit deeper and I tell
you more about debt collection and about
the discounts and b2c which is business
or consumer debt so where I work
basically we have many customers who buy
quality goods and services from auto and
sometimes the people they just don't pay
alright and when they don't pay until
outsource is this to a company that
basically handles their receivable
management's and this company I work is
called ales and a tails we have many
experts who actually sit together and
decide what is the best strategy and
also in order to recover the debt that
the person owes however sometimes people
still don't pay and when they don't then
the costs kind of grow not only for the
company but also for the debtor because
the amount of mails that we have to send
out the resources that we have to use to
try to contact people at
low cost so what we do is that we try to
offer an incentive for people to pay
which is based on a discount and
basically in a discount essentially says
you don't have to pay everything that
you owe you can only pay a portion of
that and it's nice for the person
because they pay less it's not so nice
for the business because essentially
well the business just has to take a
loss so what is our current solution
look like oh sorry for the typo what
does the current solution look like for
that to offering discounts well here's
one example where we look at the total
number of outgoing letters that we send
per month and if you notice there's some
cyclical pattern there so there's some
strategy that happens on a regular basis
where we increase the number of
discounts that we offer and if you feel
really paying attention to me there's
the little dot at the bottom of the
screen and can anybody guess what that
what time of the year that is Christmas
exactly so nothing happens in Christmas
here's another typical pattern we see
from 2015 to 2019 the percentage of the
discounts that we offer and well it's
kind of steadily been declining and then
right in the last two years it just kind
of fluctuates again in this cyclical
pattern so there's some rationale that
is going on where we increase the number
of discounts and then we drop down but
in any case there's some limitations to
all of that and right now the discounts
are offered in what we call a
one-size-fits-all pattern so basically
there is no individualized discount
it's basically here's a pile that
belongs to a certain client and we'll
offer discount XY and Z for this kind of
client so there's no specialization
there it's just everybody gets you know
one big discount for whatever reason at
some particular season it's mostly
driven by intuition so human beings are
the ones that are deciding this discount
it's not optimized in any way for the
individual or for the business so we
can't tweak it or tune it essentially
it's just not model driven so
what we'd like to do is to create a
model that would allow us to decide how
to offer the discounts when to offer the
discounts to decide what is an
acceptable factor of laws to whom we
offer these discounts and to support
some kind of testing so that we can
improve and have the best strategy and
what we call this knockoff story wrong
and I put the little German symbol there
because it's like such a cool word that
captures all of this in one to two words
so if we have a bird's eye view of how
things work at the bottom we have our
data technologies company component or
department where we have a set of
archives and these archives are all of
the documents that we ever send to all
of the customers and it just sits there
in one huge database and I bring it up
only because at the start of this
project I had no idea that that archive
existed and a lot of other people didn't
so when you work in a legacy environment
sometimes the right hand has no idea
what the left hand is doing but we were
lucky enough to drag this archive in and
tie it in with a data warehouse and
luckily in our data warehouse we have a
view that is supports model building and
analytics so we finally like connected
that link on top of that we have the
data science operations my colleague is
sitting here too so there was a nice
support where we have pipelines to do
build models and try to automate our
legacy system by building different
machine learning solutions and on top of
all that there the human beings right
there the operators and the experts who
are doing that collection they have the
expertise 30 years of experience working
cases and so we rely upon their
knowledge to help us when we build our
models so what I'm going to focus on is
the data science operations part and to
dive into the model building and then
take a look at the bias so in this case
study it was kind of funny because we
had the we had to build a ground truth
and we wanted to build a ground truth to
see how we could offer the discount well
in our system we had absolutely no place
in any database
where we had a record of the discount
that we offered them so what we actually
had to do was to go to the archive and
to pull out all the that we sent to
every single customer for the past five
years and then from this I was able to
get the ground truth so it was funny but
that's how it is sometimes right so when
I was able to get to the PDF we could
extract the deleted date of the letter I
could extract the current balance the
settlement about the deadline for the
settlement the installment amount and
the deadline for the installment and
then some account specific information
so essentially when the letter goes out
you offered a discount to close out the
entire debt or if you cannot pay the
entire amount then you offered an
installment plan so these two components
are part of the letter and extracted
both of them then for the text
extraction framework I just wanted to
share this with you in case you have to
do this experiment with a couple of
tools those PDF to text and tesseract
then PDF plumber and PDF miner and they
were all pretty good PDF to text
actually turned out to be working the
best because it was really really fast
and the text extraction was quite good
so I thought test Iraq would clearly be
a winner when I started out but it was
extremely slow so fYI if you have to do
some tactics text extraction consider
these tools in your work then of course
the next thing I had to do was extract
the entities from the text and there
were two possibilities that I explored I
went with dark ah no because I thought
oh this is gonna be great we could have
a nice annotated system so basically
with dark a no tool you can throw in
your raw text and then you can annotate
your text and then once you finish with
exporter annotating your text you can
export it and then you have yeah the
labels for entities that are in there
it's really fun to use it's really easy
to use but it was really time consuming
and so I quickly had to think how am I
gonna get through 1 million documents
and this I would be here forever
all right so I actually went with
regular expression and it wasn't xxe but
it was very very fast obviously and
turned out to be really well suited the
set of documents that I had to work with
this task seemed to be really well
suited so sometimes simple is just
better alright just don't forget but I
can't recommend the doc I know tool it's
actually open source as well and yeah
it's fun so now I dive a little bit into
the discount model so this is basically
what I was able to get out of the PDFs
this represents the percentage of the
discounts that were extracted from about
1 million outgoing letters and this is
the target variable and this is what
humans are doing so basically if you
look at the percentages the most
percentages that we offer like 20
percent discount
all right then comes 40% discount 30%
discount so these are really quite whole
number discounts the only place where
you see non whole numbers are really
below 20% where I guess it's like 15 or
12 or something which is quite
interesting to see what humans are doing
and to represent to see represented so
clearly so our goal essentially was to
build a regression model well we could
automatically learn how the discounts
are currently being offered right to
start we're building a model to
represent what we currently do where the
target goal is the percentage of the
discount so in summary for the data as
used data from July of 2015 up until
July of 2019 as I mentioned we had a
sample size of about a million dollar
million documents the clients represent
the people who give us the debt to say
can you please help us receive or
recover money so we had about five
hundred and twenty four distinct clients
in this data set and the individuals are
the persons that oh well this is a whole
lot more out of the individuals I used
roughly four hundred and seventy four
thousand instances to train the model
in total I had four hundred seventy four
thousand instances in total and then for
training
I used a subset also used a validation
set and then another portion of the data
for testing and total I had 196
attributes in the target variable as I
mentioned was extracted from the PDF
which was the percentage of the discount
that is was offered to the individual
the types of features that are used was
the account type features which are
related to activities that have been
done on the count in order to recover
money there's temporal information as
well as monetary values and then
individual information about the ability
for us to reach them via SMS telephone
number and the gender do they have a
telephone number yes or no are they
reachable via SMS yes or no and then
their gender so looking at a subset of
the numerical variables we see the
correlation among them which wasn't as
bad as I actually thought it would be so
there's some correlating there but yeah
overall it was kind of vocational said
okay let's move forward and then I used
actually boost the parameter settings
are there and this is the learning curve
to show if I'm overfitting or under
fitting and the mean squared error I'm
sorry the mean absolute error is a four
point one so I felt that this is okay to
move forward with to start the analysis
that basically if we say we offer
discount of 40% then the algorithm is
off by plus or minus four which was okay
so when I asked the model okay what
features did you think were important
what I was hoping to see with like more
interesting variables like gender and
more personal information popping up but
it turns out that the gender played
absolutely no role in predicting the
amount of the discount so it didn't even
show up in the feature importance XG
boost cuts off if it's zero importance
and I couldn't even find it in the list
so that I thought that was kind of ok
then at least there's no problem there
but is it enough well
perhaps not and this is what the rest of
the talk will be about the case study
and the bias assessment where we used a
i360
all right so the question is the model
is okay we put it all together but is it
really fair right and there was no
gender in there but there were other
variables so we have a variable that's
basically looking at do we have a title
yes or no and the title basically gives
us the legal right to take the right to
take legal action in order to recover
the money from the debtor and when I
looked at the graph that we produce from
the humans we see that there are two
clumps all right we're basically at 40
or above they get a higher discount
obviously the discounts 40% off 50% off
and then there's an another group that's
clear where there's less than 30% and so
when I dug into the data I see that if
you have a title means title 'yes yes
then basically you tend to get a higher
discount and it kind of makes sense
intuitively that you get a higher
discount the costs are more because by
the time we get the title we have to pay
to get the title so we end up offering
the person more higher discount because
of this flag
well the question is well is that fair
right should it be the case that now
that we have the title to have and have
the ability to take legal action that
it's only those people that end up
getting higher discounts I didn't really
think it was fair and I wanted to
investigate to see well what what our
algorithm or could some bias detection
algorithm at least give me insight into
mitigating this so before we go any
further the real question is well what
is bias anyway right and essentially
it's a systematic a systematic error and
the systematic error that is of current
concern to us is that privileged groups
get an advantage and unprivileged groups
they are at a disadvantage based on the
model that were built and when we talk
about a fairness metric we get to
quantify how bias our model is and then
with the bias mitigation mitigation we
actually get to
Tobias and go through a procedure where
we can reduce that unwanted bias in our
system so this is what I particularly
liked about the AI 360 model because it
has a metrics at several metrics in fact
to quantify and detect the bias and then
also to mitigate it so AI 360 is an
open-source toolkit it was produced by
IBM and you can detect as I mentioned
and mitigate the bias that you have in
your solutions I thought it was really
fun to use it's written in Python it's
quite flexible it's modular and what is
really helpful is that you can apply the
tool at three different stages in your
development so you can do it before you
build your model or throw in your data
you can do it while you're building your
model and you could also do it after you
build your model so hint hint the point
is is that it's easy for us to use it
right that we shouldn't feel like it
interrupts or interferes with our
process of building our models and
deploying our solutions what I was
really not happy about was that many of
the tools that I saw there limited
support for regression tasks all right
they mostly focus on binary
classification so I didn't I was not
happy about that but I said okay let's
go for it anyway and try to redesign our
my problem so that it fits the
classification task and this is what I
had to do in the next phase where
there's some terminology that you have
to become familiar with when you cast
your problem to use the AR 360 so they
have a concept called protected
attributes and this protected attribute
is is simply that attribute that
partitions your data set according to
fairness and unfairness and in this case
I took the variable of dummy title as a
dummy variable that asked whether or not
we have a title on the account so that's
the attribute typically it might be
something like age or gender right
that's more sensitive but as I said
those didn't even show up as part of the
disappear feature importance in my model
then there's a concept of a privilege
value so what is the value of this
protected attribute that is giving
privilege to that privilege group so in
this case having the
having a value of one was the privilege
value and the privilege group in this
case was those people who have a
discount that's greater than forty
percent and so on
this is necessary because when you plug
your data into their data handler you
have to fill in these variables in the
code and you need to know what the
variables mean so this is how I map the
problem so what are the results well I
found out that for two out of the five
metrics there was a benefit for that
privilege group so the ideal value for
these two variables one was sorry these
two metrics one was the equal
opportunity difference metric and the
other metric as an average odds
difference metric for these two metrics
the ideal value is 0 and then anything
between negative point 1 and point 1 is
4 is considered fair and as you can see
before I applied the mitigation it was
really off the scale it's really really
bad and then after the mitigation the
data was in a better quality to be
considered fair so this essentially
means that those people who get a higher
discount they don't have we don't only
have to offer discounts of 40% or more
just because we have a title on that
account right and it may be the case
that some people who have if we don't
have a title if we offer them a 50%
discount it would pay it doesn't mean
that because we get the title with the
50% discount that those other people
would still pay so it's kind of affair
right and we actually might be missing
some opportunity in our own system
because people would have paid if we
just offer them a little bit more right
it's that incentive that we want to kick
in and all and give them so what does
this all mean for you
well there are other metrics there and
those are for the other metrics actually
after the mitigation it became worse and
I thought well what does that mean all
right there and I looked around to try
to make some interpretation on it to
find out more about it and everyone is
saying the same thing there is no single
best metric there is nothing
BET's metric use it with care right
my interpretation on it is that if
there's an algorithm that I can use or
some impartial analysis that I could do
on my own work to find out whether
things are biased then it starts to I
can use that as a tool to help me and
guide my investigation and I can start
asking questions to myself about my
model ideally I would not ask those
questions it would be good if we had
like a bias review process where if one
person built the model then your buddy
can do the bias assessment because after
you build something it's like writing
code and then reviewing it yourself
right so we would pair that off and then
give it to another colleague and the
colleague can do the bias assessment in
any case I think it's really good tool
it can have experimental value so in
this case after the mitigation we see
that the classification accuracy
decreased not by much
eighty four percent compared to ninety
percent but in our business we don't
need to 90 percent classification hacks
your accuracy right so trading off some
classification accuracy for the benefit
of being more fair it's worth it and you
can experiment with this and find out
how it impacts your bottom line it might
also be necessary for data protection
audits so we are heavily data protected
and we have as a matter of fact in our
team data protection liaison so we can't
do anything without it first passing the
console and knowing that if it's okay to
use the data in a certain way and if you
get audited which can happen at any time
under the new GDP our rules you need to
be prepared to be able to explain what's
happening of course also if the person
decides that they want to know what's
happening about decisions that are made
that impact them you have to be able to
explain it and so maybe you don't think
it's so interesting but if you're in an
industry where this is going to impact
you and if that industry is in the EU it
can then audits will be something you
need to be prepared for in any case I
think it's worth adding to the toolkit
of the data scientists so that's my
message thank you
time for questions first of all amazing
work one of the questions I had is that
you showed in the beginning of the
pipeline the extraction of the features
that you use and how you extract them
from the text using the cano and using
some sort of span extraction model do
you evaluate whether there's bias in
that because one of the challenges we
see a lot of natural language processing
is that the language models themselves
have some inherent bias so you might see
it might be worth evaluating those
features and how they're extracted as
well because you might see that across
certain ways whether it's gender or
ethnicity or some other ways might
influence what features are actually
being extracted that are later used in
your regression model yeah so there was
a piece that I left out so what I
actually extracted from the PDF you see
here right it's the date of the letter
current balance it's just facts that
extracted from the letters itself what
you didn't see if I scroll back so this
data warehouse and this analytics view
this is data that we have on the
accounts that I had to join essentially
with the information that came out of
the PDFs and so in this analytics view
it could be the case that you say that
there's bias in the data set that we
used to train is that if I understand
the crash the question correctly
[Music]
oh that's a good point okay here cool
yeah what is the accuracy of the
extraction yeah
good point I didn't investigate that but
it's actually a really good point
because if I made an error an
algorithmic error in the early stages
then this would propagate later oh yeah
that's cool thanks for the tip yeah yes
so great talk I can imagine in general
like if you have a regulator that's a
good motivating sort of thing to keep
things fair because you're ready to
regulator but I can imagine if you don't
have a regulator you know you got a
sacrifice a little bit of accuracy
usually it's a guarantee bit of fairness
so you got to sort of have a good way of
convincing people around the office that
this is a good idea you have any
thoughts on that because it seems like
that's probably the hard part as well
yeah this is a I wouldn't do it alone
right it's a good point because
sometimes it's hard to convince the
people convince people that this is
important right of course once we get
audited all of this will become
important right but it's more important
to be proactive and I've read the gdpr
right so I'm a little bit more sensitive
to the topic and I also kind of have a
close relationship with the data
governance people so I would rely upon
budding up with people who actually have
the authority to enforce or to educate
others and use this as a as a mechanism
or vehicle to get the point out yeah
more questions okay so we have a last
question what was the rationale for not
using gender or other attributes just
because they didn't show up as important
in the model so it didn't show up as
importance as a feature that was
important so I didn't see that my
algorithm was actually using it as all
at all to make a decision but it might
be correlated somehow and model might
being discrimination these towards
specific groups because modeling is one
thing auditing for biases Samadhi couple
right yeah I totally agree
so there's there's also the other issue
that some some sensitive information I'm
not able to use at all right so gender
was one of them that we could use for
the analysis but if it's not showing up
I didn't know how to include it in the
analysis to be quite honest right so it
could in terms of the feature importance
right it had zero importance yeah and
the point is on you know these metrics
like equality of opportunity or equality
and equalized odds you need to define
the protected attributes and you can
still use attributes that were not used
to train them up okay okay this I didn't
I didn't try I just use only those
attributes that I used in training the
model okay thanks for the tip yeah okay
thanks yeah I think we are over time
thank you so much for the help and
[Music]
[Applause]